vacunar a los sudafricanos con dosis
fabricadas en su propio territorio esa
es la ambición del gobierno de cyril
ramaphosa las autoridades con el apoyo
de la ms quieren establecer un centro de
transferencia de tecnología para las
vacunas de aire en el mensajero antich
hoy sería el primero de este tipo en
suelo africano estos centros de
transferencia de tecnología son lugares
de capacitación donde los fabricantes de
países de ingresos bajos y medios pueden
recibir capacitación sobre cómo producir
ciertas vacunas y las licencias
correspondientes para hacerlo en la
actualidad sólo el 2% de la población
africana ha recibido al menos una dosis
de una vacuna contra el coronavirus
mientras que eeuu y europa se acercan al
50% sudáfrica también representa más del
35 por ciento de los casos registrados
de ccoo y 19 en áfrica mientras que las
dosis prometidas por el programa kóvacs
están disminuyendo
en boxes
simplemente no podemos seguir
dependiendo de las vacunas fabricadas
fuera de áfrica porque nunca llegan
nunca llegan a tiempo y la gente sigue
muriendo por eso pedimos el
levantamiento de la patente pero también
la transferencia de tecnología esto
sería un paso increíble desde fenómenos
ramaphosa ha hecho campaña activamente
para el levantamiento temporal de las
patentes de las vacunas y se ha
convertido en un duro crítico de la
desigualdad en el acceso a ellas si todo
va según lo planeado
sudáfrica podría fabricar vacunas en un
plazo de 9 a 12 meses según la ms